u.n chief antonio gutierrez says flats
that have left half a million people
homeless in pakistan are due to
countries with high carbon emissions
gutierrez said ignoring climate change
amounted to collective suicide his
address from pakistan came as the first
u.s plane carrying humanitarian aid
arrived in the country
help has finally arrived
relatives of this man have been stranded
in their village in sindh for over five
days
flood water has damaged almost all their
belongings
he helps them take the little they can
save
i came with an army team to rescue them
and brought food and medicine for them
some have become sick lots of belongings
have been damaged in this flood water
nothing is left
rescuers tried to find more people
many have been waiting for help for days
the boat takes as many as it can
a recent break in the embankment of
pakistan's largest lake has an indated
nearby villages
despite rescue efforts many feel they
are on their own
helicopters are available to rescue the
rich
but i had to hire a boat for two
thousand rupees to rescue my family
large weights of farmland in pakistan
have been destroyed millions have been
displaced
pakistan says it alone cannot deal with
this disaster which is being blamed on
climate change
and with the u.n chief antonio guterres
visiting pakistan many are hopeful that
more help will arrive
pakistan needs massive financial support
to respond to these crises
that have costed according to some
estimate about 30 billion dollars and
counting
and that
that support
is entirely
necessary
and it is not a matter of solidarity
it's a matter of justice
that justice is desperately needed for a
country one third of which is under
water
you